un scanner vous la dent ce n'est pas
assez mais aussi le paren bénéteau
comment on peut demander à chénens tv de
préparer une manière on va voir là vous
me posez vous avez tous les droits
vous avez vous pas me dire ça c'est beau
il ya des photos qui vont apparaître
deux personnalités et vous avez 5
secondes pour les classes est d'accord
et oui d'accord on reste poli quand même
ouais ok voix ou les photos calmez-vous
à l'écran voici les premières photos
[Musique]
cast avis et castaldi quand vous étiez
sur tf1 c'est une catastrophe
mais maintenant vous êtes sur ces 8
entouré de jambes ballon tout va bien
j'ai dit allons gagner vous n'êtes pas
concerné qui donne le clash est pas mal
pas mal baroudé des conflits que pékin
compte en produire tout j'aime beaucoup
maxime aux menteurs wallon jean tient
son prénom c'est tout nouveau
défendez-vous maxime sont nés deux ont
dit oui à quoi deux ce pote améliorer
pas attention aux photos suivantes
tu restes à mais joeystarr c'est
tellement pas une star qu'il a fallu
qu'ils mettent star dans son nom joey
starr
vous savez quoi ça rime non avec toca
après le voleur appelé baba pour faire
le rabibochage
je suis pas ce que vous soyez dans votre
cas conseille de rentrer avec moctar
[Rires]
photo suivante
ça arrive de l'ombre un but de lui-même
prétentieux regard de leurs mots c'est
comme un gros gâteau de mariage il ya
plein de tranche et c'est totalement
indigeste sont quittés on sent qu'ils
montent en température
sauf là oui c'est vrai mais on n'a
toujours pas de date pour un mariage un
pas vers les clashs là attention on
avait dit des gens connus par
[Applaudissements]
émission sérieuse
les kids united gauche je vais vous dire
plutôt que d'écrire sur les murs il fait
mieux décrire des cahiers d'écolier il
est bon mais les gosses c'est bon vous
êtes très vite parce que meilleur là que
la vie dans un fauteuil à peine libéré
en coulisses comme il est bon alors que
lucie les gentils ça le problème
attention aux photos suivantes alors
quoi mais non mais là je vais vous dire
franchement si je suis malade je préfère
rester madame dix jours les bleus
tombent et les consulter elle est passée
mais parce qu'après également poursuivre
on retrouve sa méchanceté alors
[Musique]
intelligence ballon humilité ces trois
qualités que jamais
moi ça me va ça s'est mis à dos rigole
aux ados attend l'amour et la femme
parfaite a toutes les qualités taga seul
gros défaut c'est aux grecs
[Applaudissements]